un país en el que parece haber habido
una única ola brasil atraviesa el peor
momento más de un año después del inicio
de la pandemia
hoy por hoy 12 ciudades de más de 500
mil habitantes como río de janeiro y
porto allegre están registrando más
muertes que nacimientos médicos sin
fronteras apunta directamente a la
gestión del actual gobierno que se ha
opuesto a los confinamientos en pro de
la economía de cosmo dale jr intrusismo
con el tema de un año en esta crisis
pandémica
la respuesta en brasil causó una
catástrofe humanitaria cada semana hay
un nuevo récord de muertes e infecciones
y los hospitales están abarrotados e
incluso no existe una respuesta
centralizada y coordinada central life
sports pero más allá de los números de
muertes la pandemia está dejando efectos
colaterales de importante gravedad río
de janeiro y sao paulo han hecho sonar
las alarmas ante la carencia de insumos
los médicos incluso se han visto
obligados a incubar sin anestesia y
cuestionan su propio juramento
hipocrático la falta de analgésicos
sedantes y bloqueadores neuromusculares
nos ha hecho experimentar
situaciones en las que nos cuestionamos
si lo que estamos haciendo está
realmente de acuerdo con el voto que
asumimos ante la falta de medidas la
espiritualidad se erige como uno de los
refugios y el papá francisco quiso dar
amparo a la situación que viven los
brasileños y a través de ustedes quiero
dirigirme a todos los brasileños en un
momento en que este amado país enfrenta
una de las pruebas más difíciles de su
historia
me gustaría en primer lugar expresar mi
cercanía a los cientos de miles de
familias que sobran la pérdida de un ser
querido una conexión espiritual que en
el plano físico está desapareciendo con
el resto del mundo con cada vez más
países cerrando sus fronteras para
evitar la llegada de las variantes
brasileñas